hey Gary my name is Michael I like
almonds and reading books my question
for you is what could cause the
extinction of the real estate agent as
we know it you keep making t-shirts and
I'll keep buying them oh and one more
thing yeah I want to keep the tick no
I've had any particular the the bar has
been raised for video questions
vaynernation take note the bar has been
raised amazing question thank you so
much guys great production
d-roc you love it right that was good
that was good stuff on yeah it was good
stuff um I actually don't think that
there is a lot you know I think there's
a false sentiment in the market that
technology eliminates humans I think
technology sets up the humans that
understand how to use that technology to
leverage a head against the other humans
that don't so you know what eliminates
the the real estate agents of the moment
in the future well it's their lack of
innovation and adjusting to the tools
that are at their hands and then just
becoming a dying breed my friends I'm
not making up or talking about anything
new innovation has forever the phone the
the Yellow Pages radio television the
Internet Direct Mail video game
marketing like like every time there's
been another innovation and that will
happen forever it kills off the prior
animal unless the animal is unable to
adjust and and it's not an age thing
there's tons of 60 year olds right now
that are crushing modern day marketing
the percentage is very small and it
comes out of getting fat right it comes
out of you just made enough money at
this point you're on to new and better
things and I mean that you guys hear a
lot of hustle for me but I I'm an
enormous ly happy for the gal that's 63
making 240 a year and you know put in
her dues and she wants to go to the
Fancy Food Show on that Tuesday instead
of calling a hundred people and selling
another apartment or she wants to spend
an extra weekend in an ass
been timeshare like do your thing like
when I talk about hustle please know
that I'm not judging you it's all
predicated on what you want the only
people I make my hustle stuff for other
people that are talking [ __ ] that they
want [ __ ] things to happen and they
want to win and they want to buy I'm
gonna buy the Clippers when you buy the
Jets don't you work for eight hours you
ain't buying [ __ ] and so that's where I
get pissed off but if you've decided
consciously that you want to have a
great work-life balance and things of
that nature then that's great and those
are the people that get disrupted
they've lost the hunger for a better
thing I'm not looking down at them
congrat let me give you a real frickin
secret here on the askgaryvee show
episode 60 if tomorrow I read that there
was a new drug in the market FDA
approved and I could take it and it
would take em this is gonna [ __ ] with a
lot of your heads and it could take
ambition out of my body
I would do it I'm my gift is my curse
you know it you know I I love what I do
but I promise you and this so many of
you are about to be disappointed with me
but I'm talking truth here I would take
the pill that would get me down to 10%
less ambition and hunger because I'd
have a little bit more balance and
there's a lot of attractive things that
come along with that balance but that's
not the way it is and honestly I'm
super-pumped the way I have it so and
weirdly as I said that out loud I kind
of don't want to take the pill but you
get the gist right and so so who gets
disrupted fat cats oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe